a Penguin's life isn't easy out on the
sea there are many challenges the wit in
the small birds including avoiding the
jaws of sharks and sea lions and Al and
they are preyed upon by other predators
such as feral dogs and leopards queuing
McGeorge from the conservation
organization Cape Nature looks after the
Penguins at the Stony Point Nature
Reserve in South Africa once a week he
counts the Penguins much to their
displeasure the penguin colony lies on
the edge of the town of betty's bay on
the country's east coast the bird's nest
right outside the residents homes it's
the only colony in southern Africa that
is still growing populations in the 27
other known breeding grounds have shrunk
or died out due to the diminishing fish
stocks and increasing levels of waste
plastic and oil in the ocean the species
are struggling the species we yeah we
call it a sentinel species it's and
indicates a specie of how healthy our
ocean is basically looking at the
biomass if the biomass is poor the
species is is gonna struggle currently
we're looking at about 2% 2.5% of the
original stock of African penguin
dwindling food supplies are hurting the
populations foraging birds often can't
find enough to eat in the ocean that can
be deadly especially during the molting
season when penguins must remain a land
for 21 days
unable to hunt that's why the park
ranger sometimes has to intervene to say
some of the birds
since poor condition is a bit of an
Arrested multi-week audit basically his
wetsuit hasn't got the insulating
properties as feathers in pretty poor
condition in a situation like this
queuing McGeorge give the debilitated
bird a 45 mil by a feeding tube penguins
play an important role in the oceans
ecosystem numerous are the ocean bird
species dependent penguins for their
survival seabirds have this
interrelationship interconnectivity we
find that the penguins you plunge diver
who they co-opted in hunting packs to
actually bring the food to the surface
and allow the other seabirds to feed
this dependence is very important
between all seabirds if you lose the one
you lose the others the Stony Point
colony is accessible to tourists people
are able to get quite close to the bird
without disturbing them and this way
animal conservationists can raise
awareness for their plight and appeal
for support in the effort to preserve
the birds these guys don't have a choice
yeah big sea big swell they must go out
and and go and forage for their daily
bread basically you know regardless of
trawlers plastic debris in the water and
the challenges faced with sharks and
seals these guys are dedicated to
survive but they still need more help
simply establish in fishery protection
zones off the coast would provide them
with better food resources it left to
fend for their own survival it might not
be possible in the near future to
observe the African penguins in their
natural environment